hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba what is your name I am a
durable rich adorkable Rachel from the
YouTube channel adorable Rachel is
joining us today we met at a something
that's artists thank you start yeah you
can follow us there we met briefly but
now she's here today on her channel she
does a lot of movie review she also does
trailer reactions as well so I thought
perfect time perfect collabs to be had
here today we actually got to actually
know each other today just within the
last hour and now we're the closest of
buddies you could have ever asked for
you have never seen a weird trailer buy
although Jones no I have not and I'm a
little surprised I've never heard of
this well you're in for a treat today my
friend I'm not gonna tell you anything
about it okay they're just called weird
trailers there might be some inside
jokes for fans who have already seen
Aldo Jones okay but I'm sure they'll be
plenty this is for the latest infinity
war trailer I think I think the entire
time I knew him he only ever had
- wipe universe against all the Infinity
stones okay we got it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
No so that's what we use
[Music]
huh I think it's good except it sucks so
let me do the plan and that way it might
be really good all right
I've run out of patience underoos hey
everyone
[Music]
whoa what the hell just happened what
was that holy [ __ ] that's our sweet ride
what's the mileage you can get per
gallon with vibranium on this thing
[Music]
oh stop you [ __ ] these monsters there's
one more thing we need to complete the
plan that guy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
humanity will still exist
wait what in the actual ass Dale why are
the visual effects not done it's a metal
arm it's not like we're trying to remove
a mustache
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so so sorry
first off I'm a big fan
[Music]
[Music]
number two I'm Peter by the way oh
really
I'm Batman oh you're using your made-up
names then I am spider-man
Oh eat aye yeah-eh just passed away
recently
[Music]
I'll do great that was a lot to process
so that was a lot of just taking the
trailer and putting things that seemed
to match was random stuff aldo does
Rachel I mean I remember seeing a take
on the trailer of the last Jedi but it
was animated but they just kept like
adding things that were in the trailer
and made it really funny
oh oh yeah I know there's like that
might have been hard spear entertainment
or tunes to somebody I remember what it
was but it reminds me a little bit of
that kind of thing I love that kind of
humor yeah I mean the editing on this
one is great he's done a lot of these
the first one I ever saw was for Batman
V Superman at times this is so random
that you're like what does this even
mean and then there are times where it
just spliced together with such a
brilliant humor I think I love the part
where a good more of Thanos his finger
all the Deadpool inserts and everything
and of course Doctor Strange checking
out scarlet witch's rack right there
that was so I saw the movie early and
that's exactly how it plays out in the
film oh really
100% this whole thing they just give you
pretty much the entire film right here I
think my favorite part in this whole
trailer was a spongebob it's funny
because Thanos does look like that and
he does look like the thumbs from Spy
Kids as well I always love when I can
introduce a weird trailer to someone
there's one to watch people's reactions
like the first time they're seeing
something especially when it's like
insanely this is great because I mean I
see this stuff online but I never really
get to react for the public to see them
yeah well here you go that's why you got
to follow adorable Rachel on her channel
because she does reactions there as well
speaking of following you
outro time transition you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belko subscribe
buttons I mean anything and check out
adorable Rachel on YouTube people that
is also your in stand and your Twitter
is and I Twitter is adorable rates just
RACs all in the description box and
Thank You Aldo Jones
send us an email saying this video was
out that he wanted us to react to it
thank you I'm so honored that I was able
to be a part of it I'm honored that you
able to be here hey let's film some more
shall we let's do it thank you so much
for having me on here - pleasure okay
bye